well hey what's up guys it's marcus
brownlee here from mkbhd and welcome to
another high definition video tutorial
and today we're going to be giving you
basically just an overview slash rundown
of the new youtube's features and we're
looking at right now one of the biggest
site overhauls and changes uh really in
youtube's history so if you couldn't
already tell this is going to be a
slightly more casual but also a slightly
more opinionated video just talking
about what i like about it and what i
don't like about it so without any
further ado let's just get right on into
this
so let's start with the overall look of
the new youtube beta in order to enable
this first of all once you've been to
the youtube blog link in the description
make sure you go right back ahead and
log right back into youtube and you'll
be able to experience a whole new look
it's basically a much less cluttered
version of youtube that we're used to
and there are a whole lot less features
that are like obtrusive like that are in
the way there are a whole lot of nice
features that that actually make youtube
look a little bit nicer and a little
more professional and give it a nice
clean look
so what you're looking at now is the new
overall look of the youtube home page
the only thing that's really changed
about the home page is the search box at
the top and a couple of things i'll go
over in a minute but the really the main
change is what's happened on the video
watch page
so to demonstrate this i'm just going to
go to click the new button at the top to
go to my channel page and visit the
whole my videos page and just go ahead
and pick my most recent video and show
you guys the video watch page
so here it is and right off the bat
you're going to notice a couple of major
changes
first i'll start off right at the top
and just give you guys an overview of
the entire page
so up here you have all six buttons that
you'd typically find to the right of the
video uh in the old youtube layout
before you enable this beta so all the
edit video annotation and all that kind
of stuff is all the way at the top and
out of the way of the description of the
video
to the right of the video you're
watching are all of the rest of the
videos recently from that artist or that
uploader and underneath those related
videos are the actual related videos
from other artists you can also
obviously expand and contract your video
to get rid of those related videos or
push them down and when you contract or
shrink the video they come right back up
to the side again now just keep on
dragging right down and you'll be able
to view the new location of the
statistics and data of the video and the
description now these actually have some
smooth animations in safari and i
believe google chrome but if you use
this in firefox are not quite as smooth
but the new locations of the description
of the video which is expandable is
right underneath it and if you click on
the view count drop down you'll be able
to view all the stats and data of the
video if the person who uploaded it made
it available you can also view video
responses in line with comments and post
a video response yourself next to the
the comments box where you hit the
attach video button and it'll bring you
to that same console that we're used to
from the old youtube layout
now one of the more controversial
features of the new youtube layout is of
course the rating system which has
actually nearly completely disappeared
with the new youtube layout now you can
like a video and dislike a video and
liking it doesn't add it to your
favorites anymore but you can't actually
see how well a video has been liked or
disliked before you like it yourself of
course once you like the video you can
see how many other people have liked it
or disliked it you can also save a video
to a playlist and share a video via
facebook or twitter or anything else
just like you would on any other older
youtube layout which is directly
underneath the video this also
integrates nicely with the liked videos
feature under my videos in the youtube
section if you're logged in
that sees basically all the videos that
you've liked since you started using the
new youtube layout so you can see all
the videos that i've liked and none of
them have to do with justin bieber
anyway the last notable feature that
youtube has added is actually something
that i i didn't actually discover until
actually after a few weeks of using it
and actually during a skype call just
discovered it and it's called
subscribers and it's under the youtube
insight feature in your account you can
find it over at the left hand side and
what it basically is is a day by day
subscriber count for your youtube
channel which shows just how a
subscriber oriented youtube has become
in the past couple of weeks i think it's
an interesting feature i definitely
learned a lot about my audience and
especially where you guys are from from
checking this out but yeah this is just
an interesting feature i thought i would
show you guys as it is kind of tucked
away in there and a little bit obscure
i'm not sure why youtube didn't really
advertise this as much as the other
features but they definitely uh put some
work into it as it does look a lot like
the youtube insight that already exists
for video views in other youtube news uh
the all comments section of videos for
thumbs up and thumbs down has been
blinded so you can't really see who's
thumbs up and thumbs down it already
non-youtube partners are now also
allowed to have autoplay for the
featured video on their channel as well
as that neat little cool box that they
also received youtube also decided to
remove that annoying little activity
sharing bar that took up the bottom of
every single youtube page wise choice
and they've also decided to improve the
way that you can scroll through videos
on different pages with a search term
with these neat little glowing buttons
with shadows also not a bad choice so
thanks to improvisations over at the
youtube team we have a much nicer
cleaner and much more professional
layout for the new look of youtube so go
ahead and let me know in the comments
what you guys think of it and until next
time this has been mkbhd signing out
thanks for watching peace